this is like the sad desperate Pinterest
version of Blue's Clues welcome hello my
name is grace Helbig
I love starting my videos yeah like my
name at you and they get a little
self-conscious and I fix my hair a
little bit and then I continue so this
week I really wanted to review something
and I went on my tumblr page grace
Helbig dr. Tom be calm and I asked you
guys what did you want to see reviewed
and a lot of you said fashion related
things and a lot of you said
presidential candidate related things so
I decided that would combine those and
review presidential candidate fashions
this general has never been about
politics and don't worry we're not
starting now instead I want to take this
opportunity to talk about politics but
in a way that I know how to do judging
so I'm going to Google Image Search the
presidential candidates and assess what
I think they look like and would I
consider a non biased non negative way
I'm just calling it like I see it
it call it like you see it please
subscribe let's take a look at those
presidential candidates oh the
Washington Examiner comm has your guide
to the 2016 presidential candidates the
Internet is so helpful first we have Jeb
Bush Jeb Bush looks like he has seen
some filthy filthy [ __ ] he's really
trying not to tell anybody I'm sorry
either why is his face look so funny
just as his faith
he's like a bird that got turned into a
human and it's a bird too watched you
like pissing that Gatorade bottle in
your car when you were stuck in traffic
and he's just like kind of impressed
with how gross and capable you are he's
guys sweet deep eyes I said I've just
seen horrific things you could tell his
highs are just trying to tell the rest
of his face to act cool Jeb act cool you
didn't see your cousin do that thing to
the Apple ben Carson he's like the guy
that took a [ __ ] at the house party when
everyone got a little bit too drunk so
no one knew it was him looks like he
likes real sweet mild pranks it looks
like when he was a teenager he worked at
Wendy's
like one time a girl was really mean to
him so he like suck his wiener and the
mayonnaise that went on her bacon double
cheeseburger and she has no idea yeah
just like that
chris Christie well his name sounds like
a female porn star he looks absolutely
nothing like that that's a little bit
like the guy that never hears the joke
but laughs like he does and then you
call him a you're like Chris you don't
even know we're laughs again he's like
my dad didn't want us to go home now
Ted Cruz Ted Cruz looks like a
constantly disappointed dad he also kind
of constantly looks like someone just
said no to him when he asked them to
prom he looks like a second string
football kicker but the game suddenly is
tied and the first kicker broke both of
his shins and he's got to go in the game
and you're just like oh it's dead and
Ted's like Carly Fiorina Oh Carly Carly
looks like that girl that always on
tears to read her book report first and
you're like god damn it Carly she looks
a little bit like her whole body might
be made of farts because she spent so
many years holding them in Jim Gilmore
Jim Gilmore looks like he kind of woke
up after a late night I'm not wearing
that suit doesn't know how but he's just
gonna go with it
Lindsey Graham Weiser no photo of
Lindsey Graham let's see well Lindsey
Graham is a man and he looks like the
kind of man that has had that reaction
to his name his entire life Oh Lindsey
Graham dropped out okay you know that is
also what he looks like that type no
kidding a little bit over his head Mike
Huckabee Wow looks like he's trying very
hard to look like a president cuz it
kind of looks like when he was a little
boy he was all his really old lady
neighbor's vagina by accident and he's
never seen another vagina sense John
Kasich looks like aliens have done some
but stuff with him he also looks like he
gives himself haircuts but the only
thing he has in this house to cut his
hair are toenail clippers and
he makes do the aliens took all of his
scissors Rand Paul he's hiding something
in his butt and he's not gonna tell us
Marco Rubio he's got that smile like
he's the only boy at the beauty pageant
he's really trying to impress his
grandma and not upset grandpa Rick
Santorum he looks a little bit like Bob
Saget and Jerry Seinfeld made a baby
together because it looks like he could
be one of those chickens from chicken
run what's that movie chicken run yeah
chicken run it was like the chicken from
chicken run Donald Trump looks like he's
got lost adness behind the ice ah like
insecurity and sadness hides behind such
aggression it guy looks like he's a kid
when he was younger that just like
really wanted everyone to like him so I
would do whatever people said and
someone one day was like you should eat
this frog into ate the Frog and then
everyone was like what's up and he
wasn't gonna be embarrassed so he just
like started yelling aggressively and
like throwing money at all of them and
they were like okay fine but like we
can't unsee the fact you just ate that
frog and he say everybody should eat
frogs Hillary Clinton she looks like a
lady that's been through some [ __ ] she
looks like she's been hiding in a wind
tunnel for a couple of years just as
that natural resting phase like the Pope
went farted directly in front of her and
she's just really trying to pretend that
she didn't hear it
Martin O'Malley looks like a man that
sees goats all the time and I said I
kind of dude I love some good cheeks
butt cheeks Bernie Sanders she looks
like that
crazy uncle that like falls asleep under
a pile of socks yes it looks like he
loves rubbing balloons on his head we
all handle stress differently all right
well there you go there are my very
blunt and inaccurate assessments of what
the presidential candidates look like I
encourage you to educate yourselves on
these candidates in more than just their
physical appearance that's something
that I will be doing for myself once I
get over the deep vivid imagery I have
Bernie Sanders just rubbin
balloons on it I don't know also my new
book graces sale the art of virginity
you have
comes out next week so if you haven't
already please pre-order the book at
grey style book calm it would be really
nice of you to do that
this channel is never going to be
watched by you again